welcome to the next talk um Megan is
going to talk about deep note and snow
par
go hi everybody um thanks for joining me
during what tricky lunch time so I
appreciate you guys um for going that
hopefully you can he some much afterward
um my name is Megan and today I'll be
talking about using and snow park
together um quick show of hands who here
has used snow park
so like three um who here has ever used
or heard
of oh nice wow surprising awesome okay
cool um I will have to report those
stats back so the
okay the goals today are to answer what
is dnote what is snow park and how do
they work together so that hopefully by
the end of this we have more hands
raised for both what is snow park and
what is
deep and and along the way we will be
doing the following to um get to know
these tools better we'll be uploading
sample data into snowflake U uh
performing in-house uh in Warehouse data
Transformations and then deploying a
machine learning model at the end to um
do some turn
prediction a little bit about me I am a
new data Advocate at Deep noes I've been
here for about 2 months I was previously
a data scientist at a another small data
vendor um startup called narrator where
I was responsible responsible for
building Advanced analytics tooling for
data analysts and data
scientists okay a little bit about me um
I am a sequal lover at heart that is
actually a neon sign that I custom made
and hung up in the corner of my room um
and yeah I just Clow seel but as we all
know it's a little bit Limited in its
data processing capabilities especially
when it comes to use cases like machine
learning
modeling so from working with a lot of
data scientists and U machine learning
teams at deepnote and at narrator um I
learned that there are a lot of
different tools languages environments
used for getting machine learning models
into production and not to mention the
fact that a lot of the data sets that
are involved um have to be moved back
and forth between client side and
service side in the process so how do we
cut down down on um that complexity
while still being able to work with the
tools that we love for me I wanted to
find libraries and environments um that
allowed me to use the Best of Both
Worlds when it comes to SQL and python
to build those robust U pipelines needed
for deploying experiments and pipelines
into
production and this is where deepnote
and snow park come into play deepnote is
a cloud-based data science notebook that
allows you to streamline Eda and data
science workflows um by giving you
access to python SQL and visualization
blocks all in one tool snow park on the
other hand simplifies the process of
building complex data pipelines and
allows you to interact with snowflake
directly without having to move data uh
to the system where your application
code runs and they're both great
individually but together they make the
warehouse feel like an inmemory object
that is ready for Rapid data
exploration
and this is the road map that we will be
going through today we'll first load our
data perform some Transformations on it
to then arrive at a staging version of
it use that to create Factor Dimension
tables which then serve as the basis for
um the data set that we will be using
for model training and prediction and
then finally we will be um deploying
that to
snowflake go here all right so the first
step is to set up snowflake so that we
can bring in our raw data the raw data
that I will be working with today is a
telecommunications data um probably
something that some of you have dealt
with where there are 100,000 records of
Telecom data um but to do that we first
need to create the session object um and
this session object um accepts SQL so
we'll use that to create and interact
directly with um our snowflake warehouse
and that is where we will be uploading
our um Telecom data to create a new
table that we'll stage um I wanted to
call out this special method called
snowflake con prop um or yeah that is
used to configure our environment to use
um our snowflake
credentials so this is the step where
we're using the SQL to create the datab
the database in the warehouse
and now let it let us let's see um this
is the data that we've loaded into our
table and we can do that uh we can
display the data that we've loaded using
two very pythonic methods that are
available in snow Parks python API so
you'll see I'm using this do sample um
and the two pandas methods which uh make
it very familiar for python users to
interact with um the python API
so that is a quick sample of the data
that we have loaded into uh
snowflake okay and so now that we have
uploaded that data we are going to um
start transforming it and we'll be using
the data frame API available in snow
park to do that and create new tables
out of it and so you'll see these are
the four different tables that we will
create from that raw
data
okay so we'll create demographics
location status and services tables out
of it so first in the location table I
wanted to call out um some methods that
U make it very uh for for SQL and python
users um to be very familiar with uh
working with this API such as this um do
select method these call methods to um
pull out specific columns and and um as
well as using aliasing and um aliasing
and and naming methods to rename some of
the columns to do that basic uh data
cleaning next in the demographics table
um you'll see that I'm using this if uh
method and that is used to do some more
cleaning to replace all instances of the
letter M with the word male
um status table doing some of similar
some of those similar things as well as
with Services table um with the services
table we are filling a lot of those null
columns and so once we have created all
of those um faction Dimension tables
this is where the fund really begins and
we're creating the Telco data set that
will be used to uh build our models and
that comes from joining the demographics
and services tables
together and you can see here this do
join method does that and something to
call out with the snow part API is that
um snowflake already disambiguates the
um field that it was joined on so you
see this customer ID and then this other
customer ID um column so to to easily
handle the the these duplicate columns
we can um use some basic drop methods
and and then once that is cleaned we'll
save it as our new Telco data
set um so now we have finished this
first step of creating our staging table
and um the first real fun step is
performing the Eda step um exploratory
data analysis is done uh really easily
in in deepnote and this is what we'll be
walking through here so um how I will be
doing the exploratory data analysis step
is by taking a sample of rows from the
newly created Telco data set um table to
use for training and then converting
that into a training set um using
Panda's data frame for easier Eda done
in
dnote so I'm defining that sample
here and let's um take a look at that
data or that sample data that we will be
exploring further and where deot really
shines to be able to enable you to do
that Eda is that um immediately when you
um this data frame viewer allows you to
um easily see stats about the variables
um so you see the breakdown of um the
different values in an op in a variable
and then um um let's see what else is
there you can also apply
filters here so that you can handle the
data more easily and understand some
relationships that might um Drive some
of the future predictions that we'll be
making and lastly um you'll see here
that we have no code visualization
blocks that you can use on top of um
your mat plot Libs and your plot Lees
all without the need to code and so
those three things so the the data frame
um the data frame um viewer the filters
and then the no code charts really allow
um people of all different skill sets to
um get an understanding and explore
their data and really break down those
barriers um that arise when say like
you're working with uh teammates who
have different uh coding abilities that
you
do
and so we're done with the exploratory
data analysis step um and then we can
begin the training step
here let's see okay in the training step
will be fitting a random forest model to
our data and then evaluating that
performance by looking at its um
balanced accuracy since the target
variable is not evenly distributed so
that's what we're doing here and the
balanced accuracy is
98% um and then also we'll be looking at
the accuracy of the
classification and if you recall our
goal after um exploring and training the
data set is to actually deploy the model
um in Snowflake and so that is what
we'll be doing here
and one other um special feature about
snow park that I want to call out are
these user defined functions um these
are functions that are defined in python
or from a l uh or from a Lambda but they
run on snowflake compute and so these
are perfect to use on our um newly
created model um that we want to move to
the snowflake server um where that will
be used to create predictions
later um and so here let's explore some
of those uh udfs that we're creating so
I so once I've grabbed the the sample
from our taod data set we're going to
use um this UDF model. predict um on
each row in the snowflake server and
then those new predictions are written
to a new table in the warehouse um
called Turn
detection which you see here we're
saving that new table as CH
detection so when we take a look at this
new CH detection table we can see the
actual versus prediced values which are
going to be saved in the warehouse
without data ever needing to be moved
out of it and so um that saves on a lot
of compute saves on a lot of time and
that is really the main benefit of snow
park
and yeah so that is the finalized turn
turn detection um table that lives
inside your snowflake instance and let's
go back
to what what we have
accomplished okay so we um after we
loaded the data into um snowflake we
performed some exploratory data analysis
steps using deep note um we then
performed um some model training again
in deepnote and then we were able to
deploy it to snowflake using snow Parks
user defined
functions and so hopefully at the end of
this tutorial and happy to share these
slides so that you can go through it in
more depth um we have accomplished five
things we've moved data from from deep
note to snowflake um we used the python
API available in snow park to transform
raw data into a data science ready table
we performed Eda trained and evaluated a
turn prediction model all within deep
note deployed that model to Snowflake
and we're able to now predict turn
without moving data out of the warehouse
and then we we're also able to return
new predictions within that warehouse um
and save on a lot of time uh compared to
if you had to move it to your
application where you're doing your
coding and that's
it let's thank our
speaker any
questions question for the
visualization for the visualization and
the training step I'm just curious if
you'd be able to push the compute for
those steps down into snowflake as well
or is that something you have to pull
the data back forward um I believe you
can there are uh so with snow park you
have definitely pandas numpy all of the
basic packages um available to you from
that python API to do that all within
the warehouse um but with by pulling it
to deep note I was just trying to
demonstrate um the ability to use the no
code blocks but certainly if you're more
familiar with like plot Le M plot Li um
you can use snow park to do that all
within the warehouse
great any other
questions yeah thanks for that talk
Megan um can you talk to us a little bit
about um I guess what the efficiencies
of having this uh being able to move
this data around like this looks like
for us at scale
good question
um I would um yeah I
so what about collaboratively like does
this help because I can like send this
data to um not just like my data
Engineers but also to like data analysts
data scientist software Engineers like a
larger group of people yeah so by
consolidating this workflow into just
like one or two simple pipelines um
there are definitely collaborative
advantages to that because if you were
to um have the data the data set mve to
multiple sources using multiple tools um
you're going to have multiple hands on
all those different tools and those
pipelines so just by consolidating it to
um fewer destinations for your data um
you will have less hands on it but it's
easy with deepnote especially um to
document and to to to document those
those workflows how you're performing it
and share it with um your collaborators
and also with Dee you can have multiple
people work in your notebook this
cloud-based notebook at the same time so
you don't have to um export those
workflows to to multiple places you have
it in snow park and just in deepnote and
everybody has transparency on um that
that PL line
there
thank you um so are there any um things
in the pipeline or any tools that you
know that are available for
incorporating this sort of efficiences
into like the query or
other um kind of Warehouse methodologies
in the cloud um or is this just like
specific to like still flake
or yeah that's a good question uh as far
as know obviously snow park is is native
to um snowflake but I would imagine so
snow park has been released for like a
little bit over a year um and so our
teams have seen a lot of advantages from
using snow park and so I would imagine
like the big queries the red shifts um
they would release something similar
although this is still kind of new um
but yeah for us it's had a lot of
advantages so I would imagine the other
um big Warehouse providers would um
capitalize on
that any other
questions thank you um yeah I was
wondering does Snow Park have any ml Ops
uh built into it within like retraining
the model or feature adding features
stuff like
that um I would imagine so I I'm not
completely sure I can get back to you on
that like thank
you thanks for the talk um question on
like the transformation steps a lot of
it looks super similar to like what I've
done in P spark or spark is there like a
SQL equivalence where I could just pass
squel statements uh instead of doing
like select and then call rappers or
whatever um only because I feel like the
call rappers are superno for me yeah um
let me see where I going to be like I
don't know snow park. seq and do
whatever SE statement I
want I think there was definitely stuff
later on where it's like your creating
table
or oh yes this this for okay cool this
is great I love I just don't I I don't
it seems very verose to type Co whatever
yeah the so the beauty is that you can
like you you can work with um um you can
work with Java you can work with python
you can work with SQL It's s Park so it
gives the the developer the power to
choose the tool that they want to and
that's why I like using it to combine
SQL where I want to use it and then
python where I want to use it yeah
especially because if you're trying to
like drop a column you don't want to
like if you're wrting SQL it's not
really a drop column it's like select
all these things all over again except
for this one right yeah so some in some
cases some use cases Python's easier
than other use cases seq tools us um
easier so that's the beauty of of snow
park allowing you to use the tools where
you want
them awesome thank
you any other questions oh another
one okay does this mean I can connect
like multiple like is it easy to for to
connect like multiple data sources into
snow Parks this one of like the
advantages that comes with it and then
um what kind of data connectors can I
add to it
[Music]
um I can I can definitely speak on the
the deep note side um you can connect
CSV files right but you can also connect
all your different
warehouses um and like your like if
there are apis to other apps like that
you can bring it in there um I would
imagine for snow park um it's whatever
connectors you have to snowflake um that
will trick trickle down into a
St okay let's thank the
speaker